[Music]
after more than 30 years and a half
dozen delays top gun maverick is finally
set to take off here's everything you
need to know about tom cruise the new
cast and the triumphant return of al
kilmer
fans have been waiting a long time for a
sequel to top gun in 2016 30 years after
the movie hit theaters tom cruise
cryptically shared on the bbc's graham
norton show that he and producer jerry
bruckheimer were discussing making a
sequel to the original film is it true
there's going to be a top gun too
i
know oh come on
a year later in june 2017 cruz revealed
the title for the sequel top gun
maverick shortly after that he revealed
that his oblivion director joseph
kaczynski had been appointed to helm the
sequel sadly original top gun director
tony scott died in 2012. the film was
originally set to be released on july 12
2019 but it was delayed from that
release date to allow more time for its
cast and crew to work on it
unfortunately that was only the first of
several delays that have since hit top
gun maverick in april 2020 the film was
pushed back from its june release date
to a december slot in response to the
covet 19 pandemic several months later
in july 2020 the call was made to delay
maverick by an entire year with a new
release date set for july 2021 it was
then pushed to november 2021 but it
didn't make that landing either in an
effort to preserve the movie's chances
as a blockbuster theatrical event top
gun maverick became one of the most
delayed movies of the covet 19 pandemic
fortunately it looks like audience's
long wait for top gun maverick is
finally nearing its end the movie is
scheduled to hit theaters in north
america on may 27 2022 preceded by a
world premiere on may 18th at the 2022
cannes film festival in france i love
aviation it's a love leonard aviation so
would you all like to see it
tom cruise remained tight-lipped about
the film in its early days not
discussing many details about it until
he was ready to release a finished
trailer the trailer was so secret that
it wasn't even announced in advance
instead cruz released it in july 2019 to
a surprised comic con audience who had
gathered for a panel about the sixth
movie and the terminator series dark
fate unsurprisingly the trailer doesn't
reveal too much it focuses on cruises
maverick aka pete mitchell in the first
film mitchell was famous for being
brilliant and brave but difficult to
control hence his call sign a voice over
from ed harris's character implies that
30 years on he's pretty much the same
earning combat medals and honors along
with citations as harris puts it most
telling however is that maverick is
still only a captain just three ranks
higher than when we last encountered him
what is that
it's one of life's mysteries sir
the majority of the trailer is based
around a scene of maverick firing up a
jet interspersed with shots of his
interaction with harris's character
however there are a few callbacks to the
original through his trademark flight
jacket and aviators plus we do briefly
meet the next generation of pilots like
all good trailers it's enough to get
your attention without giving anything
away
football fans and top gun fanatics got
their next look at maverick during the
kansas city chief's stunning comeback
win at super bowl 54 on february 2nd
2020 the big game spot delivered a
couple of tantalizing hints about what
the sequel had in store for one miles
teller's rooster does not have the same
warm and fuzzy feelings about cruz's
maverick that his dad goose did brewster
tells maverick my dad believed in you
i'm not gonna make the same mistake
although kaczynski previously revealed
that the pair's relationship will be
core to the movie's plot it's not
starting out in a rosy place maverick
isn't the only target of rooster's rage
either in the longer trailers we see
rooster take a swing at glenn powell's
character hangman driving home the point
that all is not well in the top gun team
jon hamm's vice admiral tells someone i
have everything i need to have him
court-martialed and dishonorably
discharged
it sounds like something that could
conceivably be said to maverick but
maybe rooster's outburst and unresolved
anger will make him the new bad boy on
the top gun team
after 34 years tom cruise returns his
maverick
tom cruise is of course reprising his
role as maverick bad boy the skies and
the actor has high demands for the
sequel when he introduced the movie's
first trailer cruz told the crowd at
comic con in 34 years you guys have been
very very patient with me i felt that it
was my responsibility to finally really
deliver for you i really wanted to give
you all the experience of what it's like
to be inside that aircraft all of the
flying that you see in this picture it's
everything is is real
cruz is famous for doing his own stunts
and for the first top gun he made sure
that his deal with paramount included
the stipulation that he would be shown
flying in an f-14 fighter plane while
skillfully evading questions about the
sequel cruz has been happy to talk about
this intense preparation for the
original top gun he told graham norton
in 2016 that his first time flying in
the plane made him throw up after which
his pilot pulled up sharply leading to
an unfortunate cleanup situation
he didn't mention that he nearly drowned
when his parachute filled with water
during a scene in the ocean all in a
day's work when you're tom cruise
sometimes when you're flying you think
you're right side up but you're really
upside down
really
since wrapping up his star making turn
is hard drinking ad man don draper and
amc's madman in 2015 jon hamm has traded
brooding in the board room for guns and
glory and thrill-heavy movies see 2017's
baby driver or 2018's beirut and bad
times at the el royale for examples of
just how well the man could pull off the
role of an action hero or villain top
gun maverick seems like another good
move for the actor in an interview with
gq he gave a bit of a tease about his
character vice admiral cyclone saying
yeah i play the boss the guy is shaking
his finger and telling tom cruise that
he's writing checks his body can't cash
it's exciting cyclone and mavericks one
on one in the trailer also suggest some
snarkiness between the two with a former
seeming rather unimpressed with the
captain as for the movie itself ham
seems to be just as excited to see the
final product as the rest of us during
an interview with people in 2019 he said
he'd seen some of the footage and he
thought it was out of this world
the actor doing the majority of the
narration in the first trailer is ed
harris who was most recognizable these
days for his role as the man in black in
westworld harris's casting in top gun
maverick was announced in august 2018
the movie feels like a natural fit for
harris he's played military men before
notably a notorious german sniper an
enemy at the gates and a rogue u.s
general in the rock
as with ham it's unclear exactly who
harris's character is or what his
relationship to maverick is based on the
two stars on his collar visible in the
trailer he appears to be playing a rear
admiral which puts him a rank below
ham's vice admiral and two ranks above
cruz's captain as for what the rest of
his role entails we'll have to sit tight
to find out
yet you can't get a promotion you won't
retire despite your best efforts you
refuse to die
jennifer connolly's role in the film was
confirmed in july 2018 a month before
and harris were reported to signing on
connolly has previously co-starred with
ed harris in a beautiful mind she's also
worked with director joseph kaczynski
before on 2017's only the brave at
comic-con in 2019 connolly said of
filming all of it was surreal it was so
exciting for me to be a part of it i had
an amazing time shooting it it exceeded
my expectations working on the film and
seeing the footage that i've seen so far
it's pretty extraordinary it's been a
really wonderful experience for me she
also praised crew saying that he was
extraordinary to work with and
exceptionally kind although paramount
hasn't revealed exactly who she'll be
playing variety reported that she's
expected to be a single mom running a
bar near the base we also know that
connolly spent a significant amount of
time on the back of maverick's motorbike
which heavily suggests that her
character could be the pilot's new love
interest if you're wondering what
happened to maverick's previous flame
flight instructor charlie blackwood
you're not the only one kelly mcgillis
who played charlie told entertainment
tonight that she was never contacted by
anyone regarding the new film where did
you see this
that's classified
in top gun maverick miles teller will be
playing bradley bradshaw the son of
maverick's late colleague nick goose
bradshaw bradley is now in training to
become a fighter pilot even in the
trailer there's significant tension
between the two characters teller went
through a significant physical
transformation to take on the part and
we're not just talking about getting
into great shape judging by his brief
appearances in the trailers teller grew
a mustache very similar to the one
sported by anthony edwards who played
the role of goose in the original movie
even though teller has clearly been
hitting the gym he admitted that he
struggled to keep up with cruz who was
25 years a senior in june 2019 he told
the rap i'm sure a lot of people can do
it for a couple days or a week but can
you do it month after month after month
there's been nothing on this film that
didn't take a lot of training to
accomplish i got a master class on how
to make a movie to work with someone who
is so meticulous on every aspect
literally every detail that guy has
dialed in on and anybody who works with
him is fortunate
alongside crews the only other top gun
actor we know is returning for the
sequel is val kilmer who played
maverick's rival and would-be wingman
tom iceman kazansky however there's
already a fan theory that suggests that
iceman is going to die in the sequel in
footage released so far we see maverick
attending a funeral which definitely
means that someone's going down the fact
that kilmer's character failed to appear
in any of the trailers implies to
pessimistic fans that it has to be
iceman in the coffin regardless of his
character's potential fate it'll be good
to see kilmer back on screen the actor
has been largely out of the public eye
in recent years after spending two years
between 2015 and 2017 battling throat
cancer with an operation on his trachea
affecting his voice and leaving him
short of breath in 2021 a documentary
revealed that he now talks with the help
of an electronic device prior to the
release of that documentary kilmer
expressed excitement for top gun
maverick telling the hollywood reporter
in 2019 it will be a great film i
promise this time around had me laughing
with tom like a high schooler he's so
funny i hope he saved the world enough
to take a decade and re-establish
himself as a great comedian as he has it
in him
while miles teller ultimately emerged
victorious in the dogfight for the major
role of bradley bradshaw another
contender was granted a pretty
impressive consolation prize you may
know up-and-comer glenn powell's face
from a small but important role as
astronaut john glenn in hidden figures
or from the richard linklater directed
everybody wants some he's most recently
been finding fans as a romantic lead in
the netflix original movies set it up
and the guernsey literary and potato
peel pie society after it was confirmed
that teller would play bradshaw on the
top gun sequel powell joked on twitter
i'm taking down all the tom cruise
posters in my bedroom maybe i'll leave
one two for symmetry okay the posters
are stained however he quickly found a
reason to keep those posters up as part
of his audition process powell had flown
to cruz's home in clearwater florida the
movie's producers including crews
decided that they liked pals so much
that they would be casting him in a
different role and even beefing it up
for him his appearance in the trailer
has already made an impression
what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special
some viewers may recognize jay ellis as
a clueless tech bro lawrence on hbo's
insecure but top gun maverick brings the
actor slightly closer to his roots since
ellis grew up in a military family
however as he made clear to jimmy kimmel
in 2018 his family were air force not
navy like the fighter pilots in the film
he explained i called him and i said hey
i booked up gun he goes oh man
it's the navy right
and i was like yeah but it's also top
gun he's like that's cool
ellis who appears to be playing a young
recruit also gushed over working with
tom cruise he said he has this ability
to look you in the eye and make you feel
like you're the prettiest girl in the
room nicest most genuine giving open guy
i've never worked with anyone who's like
listen if you need anything truly pick
up the phone and call i'm going to show
you every single thing i know it's
really amazing a few months later he
echoed ham and connolly's predictions
for the audience's reactions telling
entertainment tonight that top gun
maverick was going to blow people's
minds
depending on your tv preferences you may
know monica barbaro from season 2 of
unreal a dark comedy about the making of
a fictional reality tv show or from
criminal justice series like chicago pd
chicago justice or the good cop if you
don't recognize her consider this her
breakout moment in august 2018 variety
reported that barbaro would be playing a
fighter pilot with a callsign phoenix a
love interest to teller's character from
the trailers she looks like one of many
new members to this batch of ace top gun
pilots alongside charles parnell bashir
salahuddin and danny ramirez
as with every tom cruise movie these
days details on the plot of top gun
maverick are being held close to the
vast at comic con cruz limited his
comments saying simply top gun is about
family about sacrifice and it's about
aviation all of which frankly we could
have guessed however we have got a few
tidbits of the story to work with first
of all there is a strong implication
that maverick's persistent daredevil
antics are putting him behind the times
in the trailer ed harris's rear admiral
tells him the end is inevitable maverick
you kind of set it for extinction
further reports suggest that the plot
revolves around the captain's role as a
mentor to the new recruits as he tries
to come to terms with technical advances
like drones that could make skill sets
and attitudes like his obsolete
additionally per the film's official
synopsis maverick is drawn into a
confrontation with his own deepest fears
culminating in a mission that demands
the ultimate sacrifice from those who
will be chosen to fly it however before
you worry that we're going to see people
with remote controls instead of cockpit
controls director joseph kozinski has
already quashed rumors that drones will
play a big role in 2017 he told
cinemablend personally i would never
want to see a movie about drones for me
top gun has always been about fighter
planes it's been about fighter pilots
the second maverick trailer landed on
december 16 2019 and in addition to more
shots of incredible stunts it brought
fresh clues about the potential plots
and some of the characters the voiceover
confirms that maverick is returning as
an instructor and while we aren't told
where he's been a scene at the end
implies that he's been working as a test
pilot we also get more clarity on some
of his pupils the call sign of monica
barbaro's character is phoenix danny
ramirez is fanboy and miles tellers
bradley bradshaw is rooster a suitably
bird-related tribute to the character's
father hopefully rooster's flying
attempts are more successful than his
namesakes were the trailer also nods at
goose's fate in a few more moments when
the voice over says that maverick's
lessons could be the difference between
life and death we cut to rooster clearly
with his father on his mind rooster also
starts a fight in a classroom so it's
clear that the character has some
pent-up emotions to wrestle with and the
moment in the trailer when a jet loses
one of its engines is a clear callback
to goose's death speaking of emotions
the trailer confirms another plot point
that the first teaser hinted at we know
that a character who served in the navy
dies thanks to an extended view of the
funeral it's not a whole lot more to go
on but it's got us feeling the need for
a sequel with maverick inspired levels
of impatience
after months of keeping all things top
gun 2 top secret in january 2022
director joseph kaczynski teased more of
the plot shared some photos and
confirmed the new pilot's names fellas
this here's bagman hangman whatever
in addition to tellers rooster barbaros
phoenix and ramirez's fanboy glenn
powell's character's call sign is
hangman jay ellis is playing payback and
lewis pullman is bob
the director told entertainment weekly
that this batch of young pilots have
already graduated from top gun and are
returning to school for a special
training detachment they're at a higher
level than the students in the first
film which means more impressive
maneuvers for the audience and truly
terrifying training for the actors
kaczynski revealed that cruz himself
designed an aerial training course to
prepare them when they were ready the
team rigged six imax quality cameras in
the cockpit of each actor's f-18 super
hornet capture them as they pretended to
fly the plane the real job was actually
left to a navy pilot as crews found on
the first film being tossed around like
this takes a physical toll kaczynski
admitted that some of the actors
occasionally threw up away from the
action he offered one other insight into
the movie story rooster and maverick's
relationship is the film's emotional
core fly all the planes you want but no
amount of preparation will get you ready
to relive the emotional swings of
maverick and goose
although the costumes from top gun are
some of the most iconic in hollywood
history one of the film's most famous
and enduring scenes involved very few
clothes that would be the scene showing
the pilots blowing off steam with a game
of shirtless volleyball in the
documentary danger zone the making of
top gun director tony scott joked about
the scene reminiscing about the time
that he got the guys to get all their
gear off to get sprayed down with baby
oil even decades later the scene is a
topic of discussion and parody that even
the movie's director has a hard time
taking seriously i didn't have a vision
about what i was doing other than just
doing
soft porn
with all this in mind it makes sense
that the top gun maverick promos would
promise us a return to the volleyball
court or maybe this time the football
field in the sequel's first trailer we
see glenn powell's character shirtless
and silhouetted against the sun spinning
a football on his finger before cutting
to a scene of him mimicking slider's
roar from the original movie so even if
the sport has changed it looks like
there's still time for fun and games at
top gun
let's talk about some jacket controversy
maverick's classic fur collared leather
aviator jacket became an icon in its own
right after the first movie so you'd
think fans would be pleased to see an
old friend returning for the trailer
however the jacket's appearance caused a
stir among eagle-eyed viewers thanks to
the patches on the back in the original
top gun the patch on the back of the
jacket bears four rectangles including
the taiwanese flag and the japanese flag
in the trailer for top gun maverick when
maverick puts on the jacket these flags
have been replaced with two similar
looking designs in the same color
schemes so what's the big deal some fans
suggested that this was a political
decision and not a costuming one top gun
maverick is partly funded by chinese
internet company tencent china has a
tense history with japan and doesn't
recognize taiwan as independent so it
may be that tencent wasn't big on seeing
a portrayal of an alliance between those
two countries and the u.s navy however
at least one former naval pilot ward
carroll has dismissed the suggestion
pointing out via twitter that the top
gun patches are notoriously haphazard
anyway meaning that this latest
alteration could just be for looks
in top gun maverick there is no hot air
around those stunts as tom cruise
assured his comic con audience
and everything you see in this film
obviously it's it's for real
jon hamm echoed the assertion telling
people the aerial footage is
mind-blowing and it's mostly practical
there's not a lot of cg those guys are
really up in planes and getting thrown
around in multiple g's and it wasn't
just the planes jennifer connolly said
that she and cruz really rode maverick's
motorcycle she said he's an excellent
excellent motorcyclist i have to say
every single time he stops exactly on
the mark like an inch from the curb very
skilled just as cruz learned to fly in
the f-14s he made sure the rest of the
cast could handle the impact for
themselves he told conan o'brien we
hired
incredible actors great cast brilliant
and then but they also had to be able to
fly in the airplane
so we had to train them
crews said all the actors were tested to
see if they could handle the g-forces at
fighter pilots experience plus the crew
had to train the fighter pilots who were
really flying the planes about
filmmaking techniques
getting to the rank of captain in the
u.s navy is nothing to sneeze at as cruz
himself pointed out we're working with
the navy i mean incredible pilots
greatest fighter pilots in the world
and yet over 30 years into his
distinguished service why maverick is
still not a higher rank is not just a
question that's troubling ed harris's
rear admiral
you should be at least a two-star
admiral by now
yet here you are
captain
it's something real-life naval officers
have wondered too luckily one stepped in
to answer according to navy personnel
command there are three reasons why
maverick could still be a captain the
first and probably least likely is that
he started out as an enlisted and thus
not in the officer branch that leads to
the higher ranks the first movie kind of
disproves this though since he was a
lieutenant in 1986 he could also
technically have retired but been
retained something that rarely happens
and which runs counter to the rear
admiral statement that maverick won't
retire the most likely thing is that he
could have taken some time off perhaps
after goose's death a break in service
could mean forfeiting promotion or it
could just be that he really likes a
hands-on job of flying planes more than
he wants to be a well-paid manager we
may get our answer when the movie comes
out or it could just remain one of
life's mysteries
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]